I remember he wanted to play in the all star game and all the players were like,
Nah,
I'm good.
It's going to be a slam dunk contest.
But
Jesus Christ.
But what did,
what did fucking Damon Wayans you used to have a bit about Dennis Rodman
did was about Dennis Rodman spitting and magic Johnson's mouth to accelerate his
symptoms.
He's like,
if he wanted to try to get hardcore with them,
I forget.
I hope Damon's,
I'm a huge Damon Wayans fan,
so I hope I'm not butchering his bit.
Yeah,
but I think that was one.
I know that was his line.
I'll spit your mouth and accelerate your symptom.
Dude.
I'm Damon Wayans.
My opinion is like one of the most ignored.
Great.
I agree.
100%.
I used to open form sometimes and uh,
twice.
I remember him coming in on a Thursday night.
It was Thursday to Sunday.
Faneuil hall comedy connection.
Thursday night he comes in fucking yellow pads.
He goes up and just regurgitates a new hour and gets,
okay,
laugh for a new hour.
Friday night he comes back tighter,
tighter Sunday night.
It's like he would fucking destroy with a new hour.
It was crazy.
He's really good,
man.
Yeah.
He would go,
he would just go up at the comedy store and literally let whatever thought came
into his head and he would take long sets and he would take that stuff and he
would turn that stuff into killer closing bits.
Yeah.
But for whatever reason,
I think he just got into doing sitcoms more.
Right.
It was like,
Eh,
fuck it.
Yeah.
You know?
He's uh,
he's could,
that's an interesting family,
man.
They,
you know,
they grew up in the projects in Manhattan.
Dude.
Talent in that family.
Keenan,
Damon,
Marlin,
Sean went,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
That's a lot of camps.
And,
and isn't Damon's son doing standup too now?
Yeah.
Dude at Damen junior.
Right.
What a crazy family.
That's a crazy,
you better be in show business and that family or you're doomed.
Yeah.
Let me think about that.
It's like,
right.
Like if you want to compete with your brothers,
Keenan and every way ans Daymond winds,
Kim Wayins,
Shawn Wayans,
my own wins.
Damien Dante wanes.
Damian Wayans Jr.
That's all of them.
Yeah.
All of them in showbizness.
It's amazing.
Yep.
Good luck in to the,
had a fucking great talk show how the EA,
he was really,
he was really good as a talk show host.
Yeah.
He was so talented.
Fucking family man.
But for whatever reason,
Matt Damon did this one,
a HBO special and I think he called his last stand and uh,
it was really good man.
It was really good.
And the end of it,
he just throws the microphone down and says,
look,
this is the last time I'm doing standup.
No Shit.
Yeah.
Wow.
Just like it decided he was going to do movies.
That's it.
Last stand with a question mark.
Yeah.
He got,
um,
you know,
he just got into other stuff,
but I'm telling you,
man,
when he was like,
go up and above go that photo though.
The one like that was the stage,
the baret wearing stage.
Dude,
I'm telling you,
people forgot.
He's one of the best,
one of the best ever do.
He would murder that one particular special.
It's just murderous.
He had a lot of great sets.
Yup.
On television.
But just like real original too,
like one of those guys where you'd watch them and you go,
God damn,
why didn't I think of well,
and his voices were so fucking good.
You know,
a lot of times people do their girlfriend voice and it's just,
it just sucks.
It just sounds like the guy raising his voice.
There's no like female intonation to it or anything.
And his kids voices and his wife or a girlfriend.
Just fucking amazing.
Yeah,
yeah,
there.
Oh,
and then of course it's like Richard Pryor,
Richard Pryor.
So I mean he had so many characters in living color.
How about handyman?
You could never do that.
Yeah,
that's right.
You could never do that to a homeless guy too.
That's another show in living color is another show that people forget.
They forget how good it was.
Yeah,
yeah.
There he is.
There's handyman.
They don't even show reruns of that show too,
that these are frail reruns.
A handyman.
I remember what it was on TV,
man.
No one could stop saying,
homie,
don't play that.
Everybody would say that.
Everybody was like,
Homie,
don't play that.
Like every kid would say that it was homey.
The clown homie don't play that people freak out.
People fucking forgot about homey the clown.
They should come back.
Netflix please throw some money.
No,
they turn the air.
They just tried to do it and it all fell apart.
What happened?
I know they had big money and uh,
I don't know if it was going to be the original cast.
I might've been part of the original cast.
I bet would happen with Jennifer Lopez who want to be a fly girl.
Yeah,
right.
She's like,
no,
she should jump on that shit.
That would be cool.
She jumped back in.
Was a fly girl again.
I mean how much time would it take it not that much time.
She's there.
We should probably could dance in her sleep.
Yup.
Damn.
I would love that to be a fire girl.
I don't know who else was a flag around any other famous ones did that show was
so good.
I remember watching it.
I was playing pool in Yonkers,
New York,
and I looked up at this,
this TV set and it was a Jim Carrey doing the,
the,
the fire Marshall.
The fire Marshall Bill.
Yeah.
Cause like what the fuck is going on?
This guy's got a burnt up face.
That's Rosie Perez was the choreographer for the first four seasons.
Wow.
No Rosie present.
Giant boxing fan.
Oh yeah.
Giant boxing.
Huh.
Yeah.
Like people,
like she's like a boxing expert.
Not like an expert.
Like she could train fighters,
but like people ask her questions about boxing.
She's a real enthusiast.
That's a better term instead of an expert.
I mean,
maybe she is an expert,
I don't know.
But,
uh,
she is always around boxing.
I think it's so,
because you always think of her as having that cute voice and you know,
and all those comedies and to see her at like boxing matches are really getting
into it.
It's like,
wow.
Yeah.
Cool.
Um,
and Jim Carrey,
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
he would do,
he would do the,
uh,
the,
convenience store,
a security guy,
and he was just so big and so big.
So different than like,
I mean you have to go back to Jerry Lewis to think about somebody doing physical
comedy that well,
yeah,
he was,
he was a 10,
like is his energy and everything was like the fucking ace Ventura movie.
Yeah.
Like that move was just all performance.
Like what is this one?
What is this Vera de Milo to that fucking show was so good.
Yeah.
People forgot.
There's fire Marshall Bill.
So I was in,
I was in this pool hall and I looked up,
I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
And they're like,
that's fire Marshall Bill.
That's,
that's what it is.
He came in like that.
I was like,
that is the creepy shit I've ever seen.
A can't believe they have a character like this.
It was so over the top.
Do you think Jim Carrey or maybe one of the Wayne's brothers has bought up the
rights for reruns because they don't want that
blowback?
Yeah,
no,
it's a different era.
You have to accept as a different era.
You just,
people were different.
Look,
people are changing and it's a really interesting,
obvious sign that things that were super acceptable.
And when was this in living color?
I want to say it was like 92 90 to 94 92 94 yeah.
So that the way you could do certain bits and what you get away with and put it
on television,
it was just different.